comme beaucoup de Français en fait on se
demande d'où vient tous ces sondages là
que vous avez parce que ce sont moi
beaucoup d'autres
le le Macron il nous fait il nous est
supporte ouais si tu veux on peut partir
comme ça moi fait il me sort des jeux
sur les choper pendant 5 ans même si
c'est un ami à toi alors
[Applaudissements]
alors je je me suis jamais caché je
m'entends bien avec tu peux choisir avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon aussi avec Marine Le
Pen je vois très bien avec ma personne
genre la salle aussi les seuls que je
vois moi que je connais moins je vous le
dis voilà les seuls que je connais moins
c'est qui c'est finalement Hidalgo
ici sur le plateau Valérie Pécresse que
j'ai vu deux fois mais voilà c'est tout
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que Mélenchon
Le Pen et Macron je m'entends plutôt
bien avec eux
alors voilà et moi je m'entends pas bien
mais je peux comprendre
tout à fait ce monsieur pour pour
commencer enfin ce que j'aimerais dire
ce qu'on a oublié c'est que ce Monsieur
Emmanuel Macron
il a pas d'enfance monsieur mais comment
tu veux diriger un pays s'il y a 42 ans
tu peux pas être président de la
République
c'est mon avis je me permets je viens
d'arriver mais on est là
moi ce qui me
il a peut-être qu'il a tout donné quoi
peut-être que pendant ces 5 ans il a
fait ce qu'il a pu parce que ça a été
compliqué
mais entre le covid et les gilets jaunes
peut-être que ça il s'est pris ça en
pleine face mais moi à mon avis
excusez-moi du peu mais quand tu as 44
45 ans si tu as pas
fait un petit peu
un Français Delta c'est quoi un Français
Delta c'est un hétérosexuel qui a des
enfants et qui non mais j'essaie de
traduire ce que tu dis
alors c'est quoi Béatrice si je pose une
question on peut pas rentrer dans le
truc ça c'est quoi ce truc
c'est pas ça qui veut dire ça n'a rien à
voir avec moi alors
c'est vrai que normalement je pense que
c'est même pas le fait de pas avoir
d'enfant je pense qu'il parle du manque
d'empathie peut-être et que
si on est on ressemble pas comme il dit
à l'idée type qui n'est pas l'idée de
tout le monde c'est très compliqué
de diriger
une vie de 65 millions de personnes
voire plus maintenant tu dois avoir un
certain une certaine responsabilité de
te lever le matin d'aller d'aller voir
si tes enfants sont en bonne santé pour
être président il faut avoir des enfants
mais c'est quoi ce c'est n'importe quoi
on ferme la parenthèse
tu dis n'importe quoi il y a plein de
pays en Europe et dans le monde ou des
hommes politiques et des présidents
n'ont pas d'enfants pour x ou y raison
parce qu'ils le veulent parce qu'ils
peuvent pas parce qu'ils sont
célibataires et
très bon dirigeant qu'est-ce qu'on s'en
fout qu'il y avait des enfants
un peu déconnecté des problèmes
quotidiens des gens par exemple
ou et que tu sais pas
bon moi je le sens complètement
déconnecté il a plié le genou une fois
en faisant après avoir fait une promesse
en 2017 comme quoi il y aurait plus de
100 abris on fait pas de promesses comme
ça on fait pas de promesses quand on
sait qu'on peut pas les tenir on fait
pas de promesses comme ça tu peux je
peux je peux t'en parler je fais partie
d'une association qui s'appelle les
taxis de l'espoir Marseille où on
apporte tous les 10 jours même
maintenant tous les toutes les semaines
on apporte du linge ou sans abris à ceux
qui croivent à la fin qui ont froid et
là cet été ils vont avoir très chaud
non non mais il y a pas de problème il
faut il faut dire ce qui est c'est qu'il
a plié le genou une seule fois il a fait
la photo voilà en 2017 il a il a fait la
promesse comme quoi il y aurait tous ses
pauvres gens ne seraient plus dans la
rue à la fin de l'année tu ne fais pas
de la promesse bon c'est quoi on dit
quoi alors il est parfait que tout ce
qu'il a fait on ne fait pas ce genre de
promesse on ne fait pas ce genre il a le
droit d'être déçu
de 5 ans le bilan son bilan pour moi à
mon avis mon idée comme ceux qui ont
voté autre chose c'est à dire beaucoup à
masse on a voté Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
peuple a volé beaucoup voté Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qu'on peut vous dire c'est que
de ce technocrate de ce ce président de
de de riche du bérisations
mondialisation et qui maintenance
complet à pardon je vous le dis ce
complet de de ce pas qui se complait
c'est c'est trop fort mais
quand il parle de l'Ukraine quand tout
le monde il s'attriste de l'Ukraine hein
il y a eu 13000 morts dans basse 13000
morts qui se soucier d'une 13000 morts
qui a eu là depuis 2008 sa canardait
dans le Dombas il y a eu des missiles
qui ont été jetés des enfants qui ont
pleuré des mamans qui ont pleuré qui
c'est qui ces personnes c'est non mais
personne ne le sait ça beaucoup déjà
beaucoup de gens vous le savez pas il y
a que maintenant depuis peu qu'on
s'intéresse à l'Ukraine je vais te dire
pourquoi on s'intéresse à l'Ukraine je
vais vous dire pourquoi je vais vous le
dire pourquoi parce que l'Ukraine c'est
un pays très riche pour ça que l'Europe
l'Europe comme le comme les comme
l'OTAN s'intéresse énormément
c'est ma petite parenthèse pour en finir
avec ce monsieur moi je le trouve
voilà il a fait ses 5 ans il a fait ses
5 ans merci au revoir merci au revoir
passons à autre chose il y en a d'autres
moi je dis que c'est très dommage qu'on
a on n'a pas opté pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il aurait pu ministre ouais
Premier ministre mais mais parce que
c'est son option comme ça mais c'est
c'est tellement dommage on se retrouve
avec les mêmes il y a 52 sens on se
retrouve avec les mêmes ça nous a donné
Macron là où je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est que pour en revenir quand même à
la base du débat si Jean-Luc Mélenchon
avait été au second tour je pense qu'on
aurait plus de téléspectateurs j'essaie
de revenir au sujet que on aurait
beaucoup plus de téléspectateurs pour le
débat du second tour ça je suis bien
d'accord avec toi ça aurait été bien
plus captive
même Mélenchon Marine Le Pen aurait plus
de monde Mélenchon Marine Le Pen Macron
Mélenchon c'est vrai
que les Français ne voulaient pas d'un
match bis avec les mêmes
alors
Nino qui est avec nous toi tu as pas
regardé hier pourquoi non parce que déjà
il y a pas mon candidat donc Jean-Luc
Mélenchon simplement et ensuite
franchement
je voulais que je vous dise je vais
regarder entre ce président sortant
comme il a dit qui nous a fait souffrir
soi-disant parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il n'a pas vraiment beaucoup de gens
qui ont souffert parce que tout le monde
se plaignait comme elle a dit mais
finalement il a encore là donc je sais
pas soit les gens font sûrement de
souffrir et finalement c'est ce qu'ils
aiment soit qu'est-ce qu'il fait là en
fait encore
bon après chacun ses positions c'est pas
mon problème et Marine Le Pen parce que
vous voulez
il faut que tu regardes pour savoir pour
qui tu vas voter en fait j'ai regardé
leur programme et dans tous les cas je
compte pas travailler jusqu'à 65 mon
père il a 65 ans là je vois sa fatigue
je vois son état et c'est dur c'est
c'est très dur et même vous êtes les
suivants en fait vous êtes la génération
la personne
la personne dont tu parlais juste là
c'est compliqué en fait les mesures qui
proposent que ce soit l'un ou l'autre ne
conviennent qu'à une petite partie de la
population qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
toi là moi personnellement c'est soit je
vais voter blanc parce que je vais pas
revoter Macron j'ai voté je l'ai voté
2017 en 2017 et là regardez ce qui nous
a fait je vais pas me permettre de
rejeter alors on a également Sabine chef
cuisinière qui habite à Paris vous avez
aussi voter Jean-Luc Mélenchon 1er tour
vous aussi vous avez pas regardé hier
pourquoi et ben j'ai pas grand chose à
ajouter à ce que vient de dire monsieur
et puis c'était l'anniversaire de ma
mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous intéresse pas vraiment pas être
président donc oui oui
on a l'impression c'est vrai que
je sais pas qui hier il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens qui sont de toute façon
ça nous intéresse pas on n'a pas envie
de regarder Gilles oui mais quand on
voit les exemples ou de travail ou de
vie quotidienne ou des intérêts vous
avez raison sur l'audience vous avez
prédit ça moi je pensais le contraire
mais on voit qu'il y a eu total mais oui
vous me l'avez dit il y a un désintérêt
total pour le duel ceux qui ont commencé
à regarder ont dû s'ennuyer partir et en
fait il se retrouve pas du tout dans les
uns et les autres c'est tellement
clivant que tous ces gens-là qui ont
voté Mélenchon qui pensent autrement ils
sont pas là-dedans donc c'est très
inquiétant pour l'avenir parce que quand
je vous reproche pas du tout vous aviez
raison c'était nul mais quand on regarde
pas ça et quand on se désintéresse on se
dit mais après
quoi va aller votre intérêt c'est ça
si je peux me permettre
à chaque fois vous sortez un autre truc
c'est comme moi j'ai perdu une émission
mais il y a l'autre émission qui arrive
ça y est si je peux me permettre je
pense que ne pas s'intéresser à ce genre
de débat c'est justement s'intéresser à
la politique en fait enfin c'est à dire
que il y a un espèce de cliché de
l'abstentionnisme qui est quelqu'un qui
serait quelqu'un de désintéresser dans
différents qui se fout de du monde
moi je suis l'exemple de que ce n'est
pas vrai et je j'ai des tas de je
connais tas de gens pour qui c'est le
cas donc je pense que enfin justement on
perd énormément de temps et d'énergie
dans cette élection qui hélas fait
toujours gagner les mêmes il faudrait
essayer de mettre toute cette énergie ce
temps cette réflexion dans d'autres
actions qui auraient lieu
entre pas une fois tous les cinq ans
mais dans ces 5 ans entre chaque
élection moi la question que j'ai envie
de vous poser vraiment que les Français
se s'opposent ce soir parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a eu un débat hier on a eu
quand même millions de personnes qui
l'ont regardé c'était comment
l'anniversaire de votre mère
voilà je lui fais des bisous bisous
est-ce que tu veux rajouter quelque
chose
je rajoute
je rajoute franchement c'est supportable
non mais je vous le dis il y a c'est
insupportable les Français sont épuisés
tu as l'impression que les deux
candidats ne représentent pas la France
c'est ça carrément pas la France elle
est pas représentée là mais pas du tout
mais pas du mais encore mais par lui
parce que je sais que on va se retrouver
cinq ans à se manger du Macron donc
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
pour moi ça Meurice
comme autre système alors puisque ça
c'est la démocratie en fait
malheureusement c'est le programme c'est
les gens qui ont choisi oui mais en fait
tu vois en fait la France elle était
divisée en trois finalement
malheureusement Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
est passé à ça c'était enlever il serait
passé mais malheureusement la démocratie
est ainsi faite pas dire ça sur Fabien
parce que Fabien il a joué sa partie
après ce qui s'est passé avec la
démocratie en fait les gilets jaunes ça
pas été entendu on a réclamé le riz mais
voilà on veut ça on veut avoir un pied
dans la vraie politique pas à vos
questions on veut dès qu'il y a un souci
ça soit voté par le peuple et c'est le
sens du noble mot de démocratie
retrouver à porter des gilets jaunes
c'est pas pour qu'on soit vu sur des
robes c'est pas que des chômeurs qui se
gilets jaunes c'est pas que parce que
j'ai entendu des choses là comme quoi on
était tous des givrognes il y avait des
avocats il y avait même des policiers
qui avaient mis les gilets jaunes en
effet il y avait toutes les corporations
le français quand tu tournes frigidaire
que tu es le 10 du mois qu'il est il est
pratiquement vide bien sûr que les
mamans même leurs enfants qu'elles
soient en couple ou pas mais que que
ils sont obligés d'aller travailler
qu'il y a rien que les salaires sont
trop bas on en a marre on en a marre
voilà il faudrait même une union du
peuple là et qu'on se foute vous savez
ce qu'il faudrait faire tous ensemble ça
ce serait une belle révolution c'est ne
pas aller voter voilà tous ensemble on
ne vote pas parce que ces gens-là ne
nous représentent pas